all right now we should move on we have
a lot to join right can I just interrupt
for one second quick yeah sure of course
yeah um I feel kind of dumb mentioning
this on the air but I'm gonna do it okay
you've never mentioned the the sweater
that I sent you on cyber monday so you
sent me a sweater on seven Monday what's
what are you talking about yeah I bought
you a sweater online it was really
expensive as cashmeres monogrammed and
and I don't know did you get it you
didn't get it no I I didn't get it how
did you how did you pay for this sweater
oh I used a service called bye buddy bye
buddy
what the hell is but I've never heard of
bye buddy what is that Oh bye buddy is
that guy wait a minute okay so that guy
is bye buddy
yeah yeah yeah I'm the brother you buy
from these four online transactions and
business deals and so on with similar
words and things it Andy that guy is
wearing a sweater you bought for me no
no no this is my sweater man no no it's
got my initials it's monogrammed on its
EOB yeah yeah she'll be stand for cool
oh boy
and you got ripped off you should have
used PayPal instead of this guy it's
PayPal really that much more secure yes
PayPal much more secure oh yeah yeah
yeah Conan is right I always use PayPal
he's best look just get out of here and
leave the sweater okay okay okay wait a
minute
that's the shirt that I bought you for
your birthday that creep he stole both
my gift Scott Steiner you've just
watched a comedy sketch about secure
Internet transactions brought to you by
PayPal PayPal spending made safer
spending made faster and now I'm to say
more words to see how long Conan and
Andy can pretend to be frozen
did I mention scum if it was brought to
you by PayPal I use PayPal all the time
in fact just this morning I use it to
buy my aunt a cheese assortment you know
one of those gift boxes that has a bunch
of different cheeses oh did Conan move I
thought of some move nope anyway it has
the port wine cheese balls
salami logs these crackers with like 12
grains in them it was like an insane
number of great man these guys are good
they're still frozen yeah so I send
these cheese's orbán's to my hand over
here and she always just sends me a
calendar photo she took of her cat I
mean just cute cat and all but do I
really want to see 12 photos of the same
cat oh I guess we've run out of words
and they're still frozen I bet I can
make a break hate going close-up on Andy
hey Andy I make more money than you and
your wife's in here the voice-over booth
with me don't believe me you want to see
my anaconda baby
I'm just kidding I'm kidding let's see
Conan now look at that idiot it's going
closer okay I win use PayPal
[Applause]
you